all right between his endless Reckless
spending and soaring inflation
bidenomics is crippling our economy and
Americans wallets but that has not
stopped Joe from trying to sell his
failed plan here's what he said earlier
today before a bizarre technical glitch
you know since I've been in office we've
been carrying out my economic vision
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right
[Music]
okay on my economic Vision to move to
move from trickle-down economics uh what
to what everyone on Wall Street Journal
from The Wall Street Journal of
financial times is calling bidenomics
it's about growing the economy from the
middle out and the bottom up
here with reaction is Louisiana Senator
John Kennedy Senator thank you for
joining us I mean everybody understands
if you have a technical glitch but by
not much uh that's not a technical
glitch that is on purpose
well Jason here here is an
a cold
unfortunate dish of Truth
a President Biden's number one
accomplishment since he's been president
is to lower the standard of living and
quality of life for most Americans
um he's a nice guy
but when it comes to economics President
Biden is like a hog on ice
it's not complicated the United States
has the largest economy in the world and
we have the largest government in the
world and for 20 months government has
been growing faster than the economy
that's intentional that's what President
Biden wants and that has caused
inflation
and I think history will record that at
least thus far Joe Biden is an inflation
machine
now the White House denies all of this
um they don't want the president to talk
about inflation that's why they've
invented by Dynamics
and here's the argument of bidenomics
your 401k crashed
and you have to sell blood plasma in
order to go to the grocery store
because the economy is so good
um if if you believe that you shouldn't
be driving as as Lindsey Graham says
there are only two ways to get control
of the inflation door number one is the
Federal Reserve raises interest rates to
eight or nine percent
which will crash the economy and throw
millions of people out of work door
number two is to have the Federal
Reserve raise interest rates slightly
more
but have the president and my Democratic
colleagues in Congress reduce the rate
of growth of spending and debt
accumulation
those are the only two choices
isn't the senator isn't one of the other
choices I agree with both those I mean I
think you ought to you need to do do one
of those but you can also drive down the
cost of goods by being an energy
independent nation and if you don't
control energy if you have the rapid
rise of energy costs every sector of our
economy it it hurts that's a one of the
root causes of this inflation it wasn't
the war in Ukraine and Putin's fault
there's the idea that we stopped
producing energy in this country right
well that was part of it
um we had a shock to the world economy
when the uh the supply of natural gas
and oil was cut short
we weren't ready because President Biden
had sacrificed
America's energy Independence on the
altar of of wokism
but energy is a part of the inflation
but it's not the only part of it what's
cause inflation
is too much money chasing too few goods
caused by federal spending
amen totally agree uh I want to get your
take Senator on uh cocaine in the white
house because we don't seem to get
straight consistent answers
um are you going to be able as a senator
to be able to understand what's going on
with this investigation because my guess
just to guess the United States Secret
Service already knows how this happened
they just haven't told us yet
well I haven't seen the news today did
they find more blow in the White House
are we still talking about the first the
first stuff
um
look I've been in the I've been in the
Situation Room
uh that their cameras everywhere I'm
pretty sure the Secret Service knows I
don't I don't know who did it I don't
know whose blow it was
um if I probably shouldn't say this but
if if my record was as bad as this White
House's record I'd probably give my
staff blow too I'm only kidding
um you know they'll get to the they'll
get they'll they'll they'll get to the
bottom of it uh frankly
I I I'm not saying it's not significant
but it's not Earth shaking you know
yeah they can make it a much bigger
story but they could also dismiss it but
I'm concerned about is they continue to
morph their story it changes well it was
found here then it was found here then
it was found over there and it just
seems as if it's being spun it's a
different story than it actually is
instead of just dealing with it directly
well here's so what I said the other
night Jason it's it it's never the crime
it's the cover-up the White House got to
handle this real simply by saying hey
the second service found some cocaine in
the situation room we don't know how it
got in here but by God we're going to
find out and as soon as we find out
whose blow it is uh we're either going
to fire them and or prosecute them and
we'll let you know and then tell the
American people the truth but this white
house doesn't do that I don't know
whether it it's contempt for the average
American but they think they can they
can Stonewall and talk their way out of
anything and try to look instead of
looking the American people in the eye
in front of God and Country and say yeah
you know some chowder head brought some
blow into the White House and we're
going to find out who it is and take
appropriate measures and we'll keep you
posted
well they never do it that smoothly
Senator uh but that's why we always love
having your perspective thank you for
joining us hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else